macchesney Pumbaa is Lisbon's financial
district its side streets reveal a
number of old buildings that are clearly
past their heyday
not your typical residential area but
behind this crumbling facade is a rare
modern treasure welcome my name is
miguel abacus eesh please come in modern
light and airy the apartment offers 160
square meters of space most is open
space forming one single room Miguel
abacus see she lives here with his
family the kitchen is in the center and
links the dining and living areas as an
architect Miguel wanted to design his
own home light was his top priority
originally only one side of the
apartment had windows overlooking the
city so he decided to open the entire
apartment in that direction
it's ideal for his family when you have
a small child one person can be cooking
while the other is in the living room
and the child can play in another corner
you're not separated by walls but there
are regular rooms on the edge of the
apartment that do offer privacy so you
have these small rooms and then just
loads of space for the family one big
open room it's great IATI
a whole way at one side leads off to the
private quarters the main bedroom and a
room for their daughter the spaces are
small without feeling cramped on the
other side is the guest room furnished
simply in keeping with the entire
apartment the bathroom is the most
colorful room with green mosaic tiles
and brightly colored towels up in the
gallery Miguel has his office originally
the apartment had four separate rooms of
roughly equal size so he had to rip out
a number of walls to fulfill his dream
of a modern loft in downtown Lisbon
there was a hallway here then a wall
here and behind that the kitchen which
was closed off the only door to the
living room was via a small staircase
back there we got rid of most of the
dividing walls to create one big room we
extended the staircase and put in one
long floor up to the windows contingent
ecology fits into the plan moving meant
to continue the official
the furnishings are a potpourri of
styles that nevertheless harmonize
perfectly
this sofa combo is a design set from the
1960s created by Portuguese architect
Francisco de consejo servo the kitchen
is modern simple and functional with
standard low-cost equipment the
bookshelves were made to measure the
ornaments for discoveries found at the
flea market and the paintings were done
by Miguel's girlfriend all the furniture
has been carefully chosen everything
else has stored out of sight in the
numerous wall cupboards we try not to
clutter the place we wanted to be able
to breathe and not be full of furniture
in simple same seems much more vicious
this apartment is in an old building but
it's not really old so it wouldn't fit
with the style if we had old furniture
in here we've tried to make sure that
the furniture suits and supports the
design of the flat and the architecture
but the highlight of the apartment is
outside the gaol created the terrace
from scratch by getting rid of half of a
room and shortening a roof and the work
was well worth it this is his favorite
place the terrace doesn't overlook the
street so you have your privacy and an
unbelievable view we've created a little
oasis here in the middle of Lisbon
having a terrace here our own little
space outside it's really a privilege
regulation vegan advocacy has fulfilled
a lifelong dream of a spacious modern
apartment overlooking the river Tagus
high over the roofs of one of Europe's
most beautiful capitals